[Musique]
bonsoir à tous nouveau numéro du vyb
l'émission qui vous parle des
personnalités ylinoises et aujourd'hui
nous sommes avec Gary enceinte le PDG
d'alltricks Alltricks le site de
e-commerce spécialisé dans la vente de
produits cyclistes et aussi d'activités
extérieure bonjour Gary bonjour Nicolas
alors comment se passe ce premier
semestre 2022 avant de rentrer dans les
détails de l'évolution d'oltricks plutôt
bien il est un peu chahuter par rapport
à ce qu'on a d'habitude parce que c'est
un peu plus compliqué de lire le
business et c'est perspectives en ce
moment avec le contexte malheureux qu'on
connaît tous mais il se passe bien on a
eu quelques complexités sur les
approvisionnements en stock ces deux
dernières années Satan à s'améliorer nos
équipes sont en forme donc on travaille
sur une multitude de projets et en
génère un peu de croissance donc c'est
très bien de quelques chiffres déjà non
alors c'est dur de on va attendre de les
consolider un peu parce qu'on est aux
deux tiers de l'année et comme je le
disais ces deux premiers ces deux
premiers tiers ont été un peu perturbés
par rapport au pilotage qu'on avait on
est sur une tendance à deux chiffres
quand même donc on est très satisfait je
pense que la fin de l'année en tout cas
on l'espère sera un peu plus posé que
les premiers mois donc on en reparlera
avec grand plaisir début d'année
prochaine l'année dernière vous avez
réalisé 30% de croissance et Alltricks
c'est 170 millions d'euros de chiffre
d'affaires vous avez embauché embauché
aussi une centaine de collaborateurs
aujourd'hui 300 collaborateurs
travaillent pour Alltricks c'est c'est
une réussite alors personnellement en
tout cas je le vis comme une réussite
personnelle parce que parce que sur le
plan humain c'est extraordinaire
effectivement alors ça même cru encore
un peu en début d'année on est 360 là au
dernier relevé j'ai envie de dire donc
les chiffres effectivement c'est ça on a
passé la barre des 300
c'est une aventure humaine qui est hyper
sympa parce qu'on se développe en plus
en multi sites maintenant donc on a six
magasins on aura peut-être l'occasion
d'en reparler on a deux bureaux on a
suivi de Montigny-le-Bretonneux là où on
est puis on a aussi ouvert une antenne
du côté d'Aix-en-Provence dans le sud on
est environ 150 sur le site où je suis
au moment où on se on se parle donc
effectivement
les chiffres d'un point de vue humain
suivent la croissance la croissance d'un
point de vue chiffre d'affaires et on
continue on continue notre petit
bonhomme de chemin alors vous en parliez
six magasins aujourd'hui 8 l'année
prochaine en plus si magasins dont trois
qui ont ouvert en fin d'année 2021 oui
c'est ça dont trois dont une rénovation
donc c'est vrai qu'on avait beaucoup
compressé on s'est on s'est mis une
charge sur les épaules assez fortes on a
joué un peu avec les le contexte global
avec le covid et puis le elle n'est pas
encore là mais la guerre en Ukraine
affection le plan administratif il y a
beaucoup de choses qui ont bougé aussi
donc finalement on s'est retrouvé sur le
mois de décembre à ouvrir la nouvelle
version de Coignières donc notre magasin
historique qui faisait 470 m² à 300
mètres à vol d'oiseau pour passer sur un
1200 mètres carrés donc ça je vous
invite à le visiter dans la zone de
Coignières et puis après on est on est
un peu plus loin en France parce qu'on a
ouvert Annemasse au même moment et
Toulouse tout ça en 10 jours
effectivement et donc on prévoit deux
ouvertures sur début 2023 une à Bordeaux
Mérignac et une à Villeneuve-d'Ascq à
côté de Lille dans le Nord de la France
alors vous en parler de quoi dire
regardez on est allé justement en début
d'année regardez ces images
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors on voit que ça ça s'étend au
niveau des magasins en physique mais la
base d'oltricks c'est surtout sur
internet que ça se fait c'est du
e-commerce exactement donc c'est vrai
que historiquement on est ce qu'on
appelle un pur player après c'est
intéressant parce qu'on est au peu la
différence diversification dans notre
histoire on a commencé pure digital pur
vélo maintenant c'est le vélo la course
à pied là où dort et puis dans cette
diversification horizontale on a la fois
universification géographique et Chanel
j'ai envie de dire sur les modes de
vente qu'on a peur qu'on peut avoir donc
en plus du digital on vient ouvrir du
retail alors on le fait en France parce
qu'on a une maturité qui est un peu plus
forte en France maintenant assez 75 80%
de notre chiffre donc en plus du web on
vient compléter avec une expérience
magasin et puis sur le plan géographique
là on continue avec
la sauce qu'on connaît des débuts donc
là on y va en digital on a une
pénétration qui est assez forte en
Espagne en Allemagne en Italie notamment
puis dès qu'on sera un peu plus mature
sur ces pays là aussi viendront sans
doute des ouvertures en physique ces
prochaines années et puis vous êtes une
success story parce que
il y a quelques années maintenant c'est
Décathlon qui est entré dans votre
capital effectivement donc voilà c'est
un partenaire très proche maintenant on
est adossé au groupe donc même si on a
une autonomie finalement une stratégie
on est dans le même univers un sportif
mais on a un positionnement qui est
différent de celui du groupe et ça crée
une vraie complémentarité nous on est
vraiment très autonome et libre sur la
mer dont on veut écrire la suite dans le
Trix mais on est on a un actionnaire
aujourd'hui effectivement et c'est
Décathlon et vous avez aussi racheté ça
c'était l'année dernière en 2021
Troc-Vélo pour diversifier je suppose
votre activité exactement dans ça fait
partie des autres diversification c'est
quand historiquement alors je vais
reprendre le même exemple on a été que
digital on était que sur le vélo et on
vendait des produits qu'on achetait
qu'on stockait nous-mêmes des produits
neufs aujourd'hui on est capable de
vendre du neuf mais qui est porté par
des vendeurs tiers donc c'est ce qu'on
appelle une Marketplace ça en l'opère en
ligne et puis on est aussi capable de
vendre des produits de seconde vie ou
reconditionner et donc là en Opera une
partie de ces reconditionnement
nous-mêmes à aurions le vent sur
Alltricks ou sur cette fameuse nouvelle
plateforme dont on parle et alors
pourquoi elle elle vient bien compléter
cet ensemble c'est trop que vélo c'est
l'équivalent d'un vinted ou d'un
leboncoin spécialisé dans le vélo à sa
taille et qui est là pour faire du site
aussi donc du particulier à particulier
et donc c'est hyper intéressant parce
qu'on vient au fur et à nos utilisateurs
vraiment l'ensemble des possibilités en
termes d'achat de vente une question
c'est à la mode en ce moment on en parle
beaucoup parce que la France réussit en
créé justement les licornes est-ce que
Alltricks est loin encore d'être une
licorne ou pour un jour devenir une
licorne je sais pas je pense qu'on a un
pot de un poney de compétition à cette à
ce stade mais alors de toute façon on
court pas après le fait d'avoir un
statut de licorne il y a d'autres
statues d'ailleurs qui viennent en
déclinaison maintenant ce qui est sûr
c'est qu'on a on a passé le seuil des
100 millions de chiffres il y a quelques
années maintenant ça doit faire deux ans
qui nous met dans une certaine catégorie
intermédiaire je pense que l'enjeu
surtout de la dévalorisation de l'icône
parce qu'il y a eu beaucoup de
valorisation de licornes et bon et
beaucoup de sujets aussi sur est-ce que
est-ce que c'était mérité ou pas ça met
parfois pas mal de bazar aussi sur les
valorisations et tout ce ce qui en
découle nous on a une gestion bon père
bonne mère de famille dans la croissance
qu'on a elle est saine elle est rentable
elle est durable jusqu'ici donc voilà on
continue ce chemin là et je suis très
fier que je suis très fier qu'on
fonctionne ainsi pour noter les
spectateurs juste une licorne c'est une
entreprise dont la valorisation dépasse
les 1 milliards d'euros on va revenir en
arrière on va revenir 38 ans exactement
en arrière
enceinte vous êtes né au chêné vous êtes
un pur yvelinois donc une enfance aussi
dans les Yvelines comment s'est passé
cet enfance justement à votre bien alors
classique j'ai envie de dire dans les
standards dans les standards en tout cas
qu'on a je pense personnellement tous
envie d'avoir c'est à dire
j'ai été j'ai eu ce que ce qu'on avait
besoin d'avoir avec ma sœur sans être
issu d'une famille riche on a eu on a eu
surtout de l'amour ça c'était très bien
et puis surtout une liberté de faire ce
qu'on a envie de faire donc moi ces
jeunes je me suis mis à faire du vélo et
c'est vrai que ça s'occupait une vraie
place à côté des cours parfois parfois
une place trop importante ce qui fait
que j'ai passé mon bac en candidat libre
finalement et je l'ai obtenu et puis à
l'issue de ça on avait déjà parlé je
crois d'autres moments j'ai eu un
accident assez lourd à l'âge de 20 ans
j'étais à la fac j'ai perdu l'usage de
mes jambes à cause de fracture à la
colonne vertébrale et donc de là je sens
que mes parents m'avaient des coups de
retour survivant de l'école c'est ton
choix et on ne supportera toujours par
contre il faut que tu fasses quelque
chose tu peux pas rester alors ça
n'existait pas à l'époque mais ils
auraient pu me dire tu peux pas rester
dans la télé regarder Netflix toute la
journée il faut que tu te bouges et j'ai
vu que j'ai monté ma première boîte mais
en 2000 2004-2005 ma mère était très
inquiète à l'époque parce que je faisais
quelques quelques dizaines d'euros de
chiffre d'affaires par jour et puis
voilà j'ai forgé j'ai forgé ma carapace
sur ces sujets là et j'entreprends
maintenant depuis 18 ans et
j'adore ça et finalement le côté
entrepreneur que vous avez en vous
aujourd'hui est-ce que vous l'aviez déjà
avant cette cet événement marquant dans
votre vie cet accident à l'âge de 20 ans
ou est-ce que finalement c'est cette
événement qui vous a marqué
qui vous a bâti en tant qu'entrepreneur
non j'ai toujours eu je crois parce que
je me souviens petit j'adorais négocier
même dans les magasins déjà je prenais
beaucoup de râteaux à l'époque mais en
tout cas je faisais mes armes tout jeune
et une autre anecdote c'est que alors
les ventes privées les showroomprivees
VIP etc n'existaient pas à l'époque donc
il y avait des endroits où on avait des
des sols de riz ou des grandes ventes
outlet de produits et moi je me souviens
notamment d'une marque il y a
prescription qui s'appelle Oakley qui
était une marque de sport et qu'il est
toujours un très connu notamment dans
les lunettes et j'ai arrivé à jeune à
15-16 ans à accéder à ces ventes là j'ai
acheté plusieurs paires et en fait je
revendais des pères additionnels dans
mon lycée en rentrant de sévantages qui
me permettait de financer mes propres
produits à l'époque donc je pense que
j’avais déjà une fibre commerciale donc
la fibre commerciale qui est arrivée dès
le début vous disiez que vous avez bâti
juste après votre
c'est de savoir monter une logistique un
taux de proportion gardée à l'époque
mais j'achète mes produits je sais les
stocker je sais l'air livrer rapidement
j'ai pas envie j'ai pas vu ça serait un
peu grossier de dire qu'on est capable
de faire ça avec des voitures comme on
le fait avec des voitures est majorettes
mais finalement quand on a compris la
mécanique c'est quand même pas très loin
de ça et donc après avoir commencé à
faire un peu de vélo j'ai effectivement
plugué le modèle sur sur le sport ça
c'est en 2008 que vous créez en 2008
comment ça se passe dans la tête à ce
moment-là en tant qu'entrepreneur
comment vous vous sentez en fait
je me sens je me sens partir de zéro
parce que je décide je décide d'une
séparer d'une association sur une autre
structure juste avant alors dont je
garde aucun mauvais souvenir mais on
avait fait un peu un cycle sur sur ce
qu'on avait à faire ensemble je repars
seul feuille blanche je recommence à
pratiquer le sport à côté pour
m'équilibrer un peu psychologiquement et
puis là je me rends compte que le vélo
alors a pas mal évolué dans son marché
mais qui a encore des choses à faire et
probablement à adapter en digital et
donc je pars du garage familial au
Mesnil-Saint-Denis avec euros je crée
une boutique en ligne et je mets mes
premiers pièces de mes premières pièces
de vélo en mai 2008 sur le web
l'espace de stockage c'est le garage
c'est le garage exactement d'accord et
du coup à quel moment vous dites tiens
c'est une affaire qui fonctionne et bien
structurer
honnêtement je pense qu'il s'écoule il
s'écoule bien 18 24 mois avant que les
premiers signaux forts apparaissent mais
en tout cas je lâche pas le morceau
pendant cette période là parce que je
c'est assez moi c'est ce que j'adore
dans l'entrepreneuriat c'est quand on
voit que les chiffres ben moi sur
l'autre continuer de progresser que les
indicateurs clients sont positifs donc
on sent que les gens qu'on a pu acquérir
on va dire c'est un peu brut comme
approche mais en base client a priori
son conquis donc vont revenir donc ça
c'est une base qui va créer du
renouvellement et qu'en plus de ça on a
un volant de nouveaux clients permanent
un flux positif qui rentre les
indicateurs sont bons après l'enjeu
c'est d'atteindre une certaine taille
critique pour pouvoir vivre donc en
vivre faire vivre des équipes et rendre
le projet viable dans le temps quoi vous
avez dit un peu plus de 300
collaborateurs aujourd'hui à quel moment
vous avez commencé à embaucher parce que
vous dites vous partez seul en 2008 à
quel moment vous êtes deux trois et ben
on est on est deux et en l'occurrence il
est un parce que moi je les ai pas
salarié encore à l'époque donc j'étais
bénévole et le premier collaborateur
rémunéré qui est toujours là c'est
Sébastien et le bassin qui tient le
magasin de Coignières dont on a parlé
vous étiez venu arrive au bout d'un an
et demi et donc ça c'est un an et demi
et puis je pense qu'au bout de trois ans
si on remarque un deuxième jalon au bout
de trois ans doit être 7 huit et
justement on va voir quelques images de
l'entrepôt du premier entrepôtre c'était
à Montigny-le-Bretonneux déjà mais
avenue des trois peuples quand on voit
Gary marcher dans les allées de son
stock on imaginerait pas une seule
seconde que 10 ans plus tôt ce
compétiteur devait été au niveau
national et européen je suis très
lourdement lors d'un entraînement je
suis cassé la colonne vertébrale j'étais
immobilisé un peu plus d'un an j'ai
découvert Internet et le e-commerce à ce
moment-là parce que je pouvais plus
bouger et de ma passion en fait j'ai
essayé de transposer ça sur un modèle
commercial donc le e-commerce et
l'aventure est née en mai 2008 donc
autour du vélo c'est donc de son lit que
Gary se lance dans la vente de pièces
détachées et accessoires pour vélo et
donne naissance à Alltricks avec
seulement 6000 euros
6000 c'est aussi le nombre de mètres
carrés sur lesquels est désormais
installé son entreprise aujourd'hui
Alltricks c'est 45 salariés 17000
références en stock et un chiffre
d'affaires en 2013 de 20 millions
d'euros à 30 ans Gary compte bien passer
au braquet supérieur la majeure partie
de l'activités est concentrée sur la
France aujourd'hui et le challenge pour
2014 c'est de
d'avancer sur des pays comme le Portugal
l'Espagne l'Italie où il y a peu de
sites internet dans le vélo aujourd'hui
et pour autant beaucoup de pratiquants
consécration pour l'entreprise de Gary
après le vélo Drôme national Alltricks
sera partenaire d'ASO pour le tout
premier rock Paris où se donneront
rendez-vous des milliers de vététistes
du 28 au 30 mars prochain
Mantes-la-Jolie
alors voilà depuis ces images
l'entreprise a évolué qu'est-ce que on
peut vous souhaiter aussi pour l'avenir
maintenant et bien j'ai envie de
continuer j'ai envie de dire de
continuer sur la même dynamique parce
que alors je suis pas très objectif mais
je pense on mérite en grande partie ce
que l'on a parce qu'on a recruté des
gens formidables au cours de l'histoire
on a tout fait pour les fédérer dans le
temps et qu'on soit un beau projet
ensemble l'enjeu maintenant dans un
monde qui bouge très très vite c'est de
réussir à avoir une lisibilité qui est
bonne parce qu'il y a de plus en plus
d'acteurs qui se digitalisent on a la
chance d'être sur un marché qui est en
pleine expansion alors le vélo parce que
la dimension mobilité douce donc les
nouveaux usagers du vélo on est
forcément dans une dimension sportive
dans une dimension transport se
développe énormément et puis la houdeur
qui a un nouveau terrain de jeu pour
nous énormément aussi parce que les gens
notamment pendant les confinements ont
pris conscience des bienfaits de
l'extérieur donc voilà cette continuer à
cette continuer sur cette dynamique là
parce que c'est peut-être un point que
je mettrai en exergue c'est que la
croissance c'est super évidemment on a
tous envie d'être en croissance mais
quelque chose de très c'est quelque
chose de très déstabilisant quand on
passe de on l'a dit il y a 10 ans on
était 8 on est 360 maintenant il faut
structurer l'entreprise il faut trouver
les locaux qui vont bien il faut faire
grimper la structure managériale les
avantages qu'on offre collaborateurs
c'est partenaires etc dans le temps et
il faut que tout ça tienne donc il faut
construire en même temps qu'on marche
c'est pas toujours évident on a quelques
jours de du Big tour c'est une sorte de
festival des entrepreneurs ce sera juste
à côté de chez vous c'est au Vélodrome
national de Saint-Quentin en Yvelines
c'est le 20 septembre prochain parlons
d'entrepreneuriat justement vous pour
vous l'entrepreneuriat c'est quoi
pour moi c'est un rêve alors que je vis
éveiller non je sens faire de la magie
l'entrepreneur c'est de la liberté donc
c'est une liberté qui a un prix parce
que c'est pas tous les jours facile
c'est un vrai sujet de savoir si on le
fait seul si on s'associe si on le fait
seul c'est un vrai sujet de bien
s'entourer derrière parce qu'elle a le
sujet de je suis seul à je suis le seul
au départ impulser un projet mais on
fait pas grand chose seul dans tous les
cas derrière donc il faut avoir la bonne
équipe c'est je pense avoir une
résilience face aux problématiques assez
fortes en fait il faut vraiment voir ça
comme un apprentissage et pas comme un
échec parce que sinon c'est plus très
vite parce que l'entrepreneur c'est que
des problématiques elles sont parfois
hyper moi c'est comme ça que je vois les
choses aujourd'hui excitantes parce que
quand on trouve la clé d'un problème
c'est très amusant vous avez un exemple
là comme ça vous me prenez un peu de
cours mais oui j'en ai en ce moment ben
non mais en ce moment c'est hyper
intéressant et pourtant c'est une vraie
problématique on a un pouvoir d'achat
qui se réduit avec le contexte qu'on
connaît tous donc on fait monter le SMIC
et des revenus minimum ce que je trouve
très bien et donc comme vous avez une
pyramide de salaire avec une structure
en place ça vient pousser par le bas
j'ai envie de dire tous cette structure
là toute cette structure là pardon donc
il faut évidemment m'accompagner tout le
monde et dans une équation globale de ma
salariale c'est un réel enjeu mais il
faut le faire et puis le deuxième on
parlait de licorne tout à l'heure il y a
beaucoup d'entreprises mérité ou pas
mérité je veux pas rentrer dans le débat
mais qui ont enlevé beaucoup de fond sur
les dernières années qui recruté de
manière massive sans trop regarder les
niveaux de salaire parce qu'elle voulait
absolument certain profils et ça ça fait
monter énormément les enchères aussi et
donc il faut tenir ça dans le temps et
réussir à garder des entreprises
rentables tout en géance paramètres là
donc c'est pas toujours c'est pas
toujours évident mais c'est intéressant
vous êtes une succès story 56 yvelinoise
merci
quelles sont les clés de la réussite
justement dans l'entrepreneuriat c'est à
dire comme question ça
je pense qu'il faut
je pense qu'il faut garder la tête
froide c'est ce que c'est ce que je
disais un peu avant je pense qu'il faut
faut
rester lucide il faut avoir un
discernement qui est fort parce qu'en
fait on peut vite s'emballer en disant
bon les premiers indicateurs sont bons
c'est acquis fait c'est jamais acquis je
l'ai dit aussi c'est la clé il faut bien
s'entourer je pense qu'il faut beaucoup
écouter il faut faire attention à pas à
pas forger une auto persuasion donc on
comprend souvent les bonnes décisions
soi-même parce que c'est le meilleur
moyen de se mettre dans le mur et voilà
c'est s'entourer c'est cette équilibré
donc c'est la vie de famille c'est le
sport c'est les patients à côté parce
qu'il y a pas que ça même si c'est un
très gros bout de la vie d'un
entrepreneur et puis voilà c'est y
croire c'est croire c'est la base pour
moi c'est la passion parce que si on
fait ça pour pour l'argent pour la
gloire on y arrivera jamais quoi et la
passion du vélo qui a permis de créer
cette longue histoire qu'on a derrière
vous l'histoire d'altricks merci Gary
Hans merci à vous je rappelle fondateur
et PDG de la société Alltricks basée à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux c'est la fin de
ce V YP merci de l'avoir suivi
l'émission que vous pouvez revoir en
replay sur notre site Internet ou sur
l'application mobile à bientôt sur TV 78
[Musique]